حسنًا للمشاهدين المنتظمين لـ CNN وهذا
العرض على وجه التحديد سوف تتعرف
على وجه مألوف يقدم تقارير من
مناطق النزاع في بعض المناطق النائية
من العالم على حد سواء على مدى السنوات الـ 18 الماضية ،
لقد وضع damon لدينا معيارًا
للصحافة الشجاعة بقلب
واليوم
للأسف هو يومها الأخير حيث أن CNN هي
مراسلة دولية رفيعة المستوى
اشتهرت بروايتها للقصص الرحيمة
بسبب تعاملها مع مواضيعها بإنسانية
وحساسية في كل
حزمة تلفزيونية وكل قطعة رقمية كانت
قد مرت بها رحلة رائعة وبصراحة تامة ،
فهي تعترف بأنها هي نفسها.  بدأت
حياتها المهنية أه في عام 2003 في مكتب بغداد في
تغطية بعض
أحلك أيام الحرب في العراق عام 2012
، كانت من أوائل الصحفيين الذين
وصلوا إلى بنغازي ليبيا بعد
الهجوم على سفارة الولايات المتحدة هناك
وغطت الحرب على نطاق واسع  ضد تنظيم
الدولة في العراق وسوريا حتى محاصرة
لمدة 28 ساعة في الموصل بعد أن
تعرضت قافلة فريقها لكمين و  استولت
عليها المجموعة الإرهابية بغض النظر عن المكان
الذي ذهبت إليه ، ظل الجانب الإنساني من القصة
حجر الزاوية في
تقاريرنا وكانت تجربتها الشخصية في
مناطق الحرب هي التي دفعتها إلى إطلاق منظمة
غير ربحية تسمى inara تقدم
الرعاية الطبية للأطفال الذين يحتاجون إليها.
العلاج المنقذ للحياة جيدًا في
مذكرة الوداع
التي كتبتها إلى الشبكة التي كتبتها لزملائها وأقتبس إنني
أصبحت عاطفيًا الآن ، لذا سننهي هذا
بالقول
إنه لشرف لي أن أحظى بحياة
تمكنت من الحصول على أفكار وفي
الواقع  ملاحقتهم ، هذا هو آخر من
تلك التقاطعات في الحياة ، وقد حان الوقت
بالنسبة لي لأرى إلى أين يسير هذا المسار المجنون ،
إنه أمر مزعج
لكنني متحمس ، وبعد كل شيء إذا كنت
تعرفني فأنت تعلم أنني أكثر خوفًا
من العيش مع أه ماذا لو أو  إذا
كنت فقط من المجازفة وفشلت ،
انضمت إلي لارا الآن
لآخر مرة ، اعتقد الناس أنك مجنون ،
آه عندما توليت هذه الوظيفة في CNN ، لكنك
استمتعت أه انتهى الأمر بالإبلاغ
خلال بعض أه
أه أحلك الأيام  من  حرب العراق
وغيرها تعكس فقط أه على بعض أه
ما عايشته مع CNN إذا
كنت أعني أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، يجب أن أقول إنني
قد تأثرت تمامًا
بالرد اللطيف والسخي والداعم
الذي تلقيته  حصلت ونعم تعلم أن تلك
السنوات التي أمضيتها في العراق
شكلت
من أنا هم الذين حددوا من أنا ولكن
لم تكن بالضرورة لحظات
الظلام التي
عشناها كمكتب في بغداد سواء كانت
انفجارات أو عمليات قتل أو مدى عمق
و  أنت تعرف بعمق أن ما كان
يحدث في شوارع العراق كان
يؤثر على أصدقائنا على
عائلة سي إن إن بغداد ، موظفينا العراقيون ، ما
يميزني حقًا عندما أنظر
إلى الوراء في تلك السنوات هو هذه
الصداقة الحميمة التي كانت لدينا في
المكتب بالطريقة التي
كنا بها باستمرار  يدعمون بعضهم البعض
وهناك قصة واحدة على وجه الخصوص أن
مجرد التفكير في الحديث عنها
يصيبني بالقشعريرة وهي أنكم تعرفون
قصة هذا الطفل الصغير الذي يدعى يوسف الذي
كان يبلغ من العمر خمس سنوات عندما قابلته قناة سي إن إن.
كان قد ألقي بنزين على
وجهه ، أضرم فيه رجال ملثمون مجهولون
، والوقت الذي حدث
فيه ذلك لم يكن
مجرد
أن الناس لم يهتموا
بالعراق في الوقت الذي كان فيه هذا
الاكتئاب قد تغلغل
بالعراقيين حقًا.  تغلغلت في المكتب
وعندما أبلغنا عن قصة يوسف لـ CNN ،
كان الرد على ذلك
غامرًا
للغاية وأسفر عن الذهاب إلى أمريكا
والحصول على الرعاية الطبية وفرحة
والديه ،
فقد تبنينا أن
فرحتهم أصبحت فرحتنا وصدرت لنا.  معًا بطريقة
لا تنفصم تمامًا ، عدنا معًا الآن
وهو جميل